xbox series x launches in november halo
infinite has been delayed to 2021
and sam fisher is coming to rainbow six
siege it's a big news day i'm chasity
and you've reached your save state for
tuesday
august 11th
we're one step closer to a release date
for the xbox series x as microsoft has
confirmed
that the series x is coming this
november there's no specific day just
yet but microsoft confirmed via blog
post on the xbox wire that the series x
is launching in november
in the announcement microsoft plugged
its 50 plus brand new games coming to
the series x
and 40 plus existing games that will be
optimized for it
a bunch of those new games will be
available day one on game pass including
exclusives like tetris effect connected
the medium and scorn
there's still no word on price or the
series s which is the cheaper version
previously known as lockhart
one major game that won't launch with
series x is halo infinite which has been
delayed to 2021.
halo infinite has been delayed to 2021
largely due to development difficulties
from kovid 19.
343 industries shared a statement on
twitter saying quote we have made the
difficult decision to shift our release
to 2021 to ensure the team has adequate
time to deliver a halo game experience
that meets our vision
we did get to see some gameplay at a
recent xbox showcase revealing master
chief's new grappling hook
and we also learned recently that the
multiplayer component of the game will
be free to play
that doesn't appear to have changed with
this delay
and finally splinter cell's sam fisher
is coming to rainbow six siege as a
playable character
the next rainbow six siege season is
operation shadow legacy and as usual
it's adding two new operators
in a reveal trailer it was announced
that one of them is sam fisher from
splintercell
his code name is zero and details on how
he'll function in siege have yet to be
revealed we don't know who the second
new operator is yet
but the full reveal for the new season
is coming this sunday august 16th at 11
a.m pacific time and 2 p.m eastern
so that's the news for today but just a
reminder that we're still raising money
for charity with the gamespot store
head over to store.gamespot.com to buy
cool play for all merch including face
masks
t-shirts hoodies and a very rad
skateboard all proceeds go to charity
until the end of august so go to the
store buy something cool and help us
raise money for a good cause
and that's your save save for tuesday
are you excited for the series x let me
know in the comments below or reach out
to me on twitter i'm at chastity
underscore v
and i'll see you next time
you